well one of the things to consider in
the new year is what health plan is best
for you and your family in 2023 Nevada
open enrollment ends January 15th and
here to discuss some available options
is Anna Landers of Select Health Nevada
Anna thank you for being here we
mentioned that deadline so everybody has
an opportunity to review their old plan
and decide if they want a new one but
they need well they have about a week
and a half left to do so absolutely
Nevada actually has an extended day line
deadline sorry which is January 15th
which would give you coverage starting
February 1st so we do offer our plans
through Nevada Health Link or you can
also go direct with Select Health but
definitely keep that date in mind
because we don't want to go without
health insurance it's a priority yeah
and you say this is a good opportunity
to review your existing coverage because
a lot of people just let it roll over to
the next year but you want to check what
benefits are available and what's best
for your family absolutely yes so of
course life changes from year to year
um definitely check out what is
available to you your subsidies if you
qualify for any new subsidies and we
actually have new options for 2023 our
diabetes support plan all of our
individual plants actually are going to
cover chronic condition medications at
no cost so if you're a diabetic COPD or
asthma there's medications that are
covered at no cost pre-deductible which
could be a tremendous savings for a lot
of people with chronic conditions
exactly what are some other things that
are new this year that people should
look for so our co-pay plan is a very
popular option you don't have to worry
about deductible a straightforward plan
co-pays only
um
preventive services are always going to
be covered at a hundred percent so zero
copay in those cases yeah so just
keeping you healthy along those lines we
offer Wellness rewards so our Wellness
rewards basically
put money back in your pocket for
keeping for staying healthy whether
you're doing your preventive Services
going to the gym walking
staying healthy we'll give you twenty
dollars a month
um which you could use for a gym
membership or anything you want really
that's a great idea
what are some ways people can get
information if they're not sure what
plan is best for them or and their
family definitely give us a call or go
to selectthealth.org we also recommend
to use an agent if you have any
questions agents are a great resource or
like I mentioned Nevada Health thing all
right Anna thanks so much for being here
today appreciate it very much appreciate
it thank you if you want more
information you can give this phone
number a call at Select Health
1-855-442-0220 or go to
selectthealth.org we'll be back